let's go next to our caller from the 2:8
one area code who's calling today from
two eight one hello yes it is okay hello
David my name is Michel how are you
doing today
good thank you I wanted to ask you just
a more fun question if that's all right
so I'm a Spanish major at University of
Houston and as someone who's really
interested in linguistics I was
wondering if whenever you've interacted
with Spanish speakers either from the
United States
you know Mexico more North America do
they have trouble understanding your
Argentinian accent at all no because I
modulate my my vocabulary so that it is
easier for them to understand so instead
of saying voice I say do and I conjugate
the way that they would be used to so I
mean I'm modulating my Spanish when I
know that I'm speaking to a non
Argentinian and when you like so I think
the double Elliot like it has the Y
noise oh yeah I don't do that I don't do
that that'd that's too including that c4
need like I like I have a hard time
understanding the Argentinian accent
just because of that is it's such a
different noise than the Y noise that
I'm used to
that's interesting yeah I'm watching a
show on Netflix right now called
in English they've translated it as
money heist it's a Spanish show like
from Spain and there's a lot of Spanish
slang and fast-talking and I have
trouble understanding that like I put
the Spanish subtitles on to be able to
see what they're saying cuz that's very
unclear for me but like Argentinian
Spanish just because it's what I grew up
around is super easy to understand yeah
that's really interesting to hear okay
thank you for answering my question
David have a good day all right you too
thank you for the call